februari is educational hip-hop videos
for 11 students q 2 12 hold in subjects
and they have social studies science
vocabulary Everett items so I love music
and I love unisex between music and
education it was the entire idea of how
vocabulary started and I started fire
founders as a way for them to be able to
memorize vocabulary words or other
faction or taking tests and so I'm very
like obsessed with people like Leah up
using music as an educational tool and
how it can actually get you to
understand things and not just
understand like memorizing and learn the
van hit me inside you and so I guess
this job is just like such a thrill
because I can't overdose an amazing
product you know I hip hop in the
classroom and being able to kind of like
oversee it and make just like this
company better disa like this is just
the intersection of music education it's
like wait communism's you know we do
what we do with all we can wrap whereas
kind of a weekly roundup of all the
events on during that week and so we
have rapper rapid and there's kind of
ennis first with the video a lot of
footage of the week's events and
everything seventy sustainable
development goes this gets all because
the more you and so I went to this
school visit and teacher plate that of
the students and the students are just
you know they they just were so excited
to like you know not just absorb what
happened America just to hear the rap
and your the song and muninn effort
after it was over that we went through
like a little um like challenge
questions that we have
site where they kind of answer some
questions about the video and everything
and so you know they were in a lot of
like discussing a lot of talking about i
count what's going on in this video and
everything and so to see like how
excited everyone raised their hands and
you know just see like the excitement
about the topics was just really really
cool I think especially in our CS
program we had already kind of smaller
tight-knit groups were we kind of work
to work to do platoon 23 seems like that
you know in our projects and we've had a
very kind of problem i start up like
atmospheres and and it was just abrade
laid back but very hard working
atmosphere
you